monsieur le ministre avant de poser ma
question je souhaiterais demander à
monsieur le ministre délégué au
transport de cesser de laisser entendre
comme il l'a fait mercredi dernier dans
cette hémicycle que vous allez investir
12 milliards cette année dans le réseau
ferroviaire car c'est faux et pour vous
paraphraser c'est ça lesbrooke à la
différence des moyens supplémentaires
voté par le Parlement nous sommes au
dernier rang européen avec la Lituanie
concernant la modernisation de notre
réseau nos lignes ferroviaires vont être
ralenties ou fermés les unes après les
autres faute d'investissement si vous ne
réagissez pas fortement pour cela
écoutez plus souvent les appels du Sénat
comme sur la question des ZF zones à
faible émission nous avions proposé lors
de l'examen de la loi climat et
résilience un certain nombre de mesures
pour obtenir l'adhésion de nos
concitoyens car oui il y a urgence à
décarboner nos transports pour cause de
santé publique mais pour faire accepter
une réforme qui va impacter d'ici à deux
ans près de 40% du par automobile et
donc des Français il faut informer
écouter accompagner ce qui n'avait pas
été fait jusqu'à enfin la semaine
dernière devant les 43 présidents
d'agglomération concernés vous avez
repris quelques propositions du Sénat
rejetées à l'époque par la ministre
Pompili comme le prêt à taux zéro la
révision du schéma de restriction et
l'inéfectivité des contrôles mais le
préalable à tout ça demeure un
développement massif de l'offre de
transport en commun de la France
périphérique vers nos agglomérations
pour réduire cette fracture qui mine
notre pays monsieur le ministre à défaut
de freinage d'urgence ou de
rétropédalage n'est-il pas temps avec
pragmatisme de revoir l'ensemble du
dispositif des zones affaiblissement